[Music]
[Music]
william we're here yes we are we're back
and we're in a mad rush because we've
had so many correspondents this week and
we don't have a huge amount of time
because we've got a fantastic guest
we've got a ton of stuff to get through
in what order should we do it what do
you think dom you've hit the road
proverbially
i'm excited i've been i've been drinking
a little bit of this scarlet um male cow
drink
and uh it's got me quite excited i can
see that well
this show be done in about 12 minutes
where you're going yeah i uh on the uh
worldwide interfeeds yes this week i
mentioned that i made a good scrambled
egg uh dish have you had my scrambled
eggs
i haven't i'd love to scramble my eggs
for you i'll tell you something before
we get into your recipe i'm sure it's
absolutely it's superb guam
you have another strange uh thing about
you tom
and there's many thank you but um one of
them is you
you don't like people cooking you eggs i
don't really like people who i don't
know cooking me eggs but there's a
strange thing there because i'm i seem
to be okay with it in a restaurant and
clearly i don't know all the chefs
but if i'm over at someone's house yeah
i'd be more than delighted to have you
cook me breakfast okay included eggs or
your wife
even your son because i i'm i know you
guys but like if you and i went over to
a friend's house yeah that i didn't know
and they were like see a friend of mine
just a friend who we've gone surfing
with and they're like hey i'll make a
quick breakfast because everyone likes
scrambled eggs i'd be like not for me
i'll just have the toast weird then
weird strange let me give you my
scrambled egg thing right hold on till i
get settled in which
i can't take full credit for because a
this is how my mom and dad
have always made scrambled eggs and b
this is how gordon ramsay did it so when
i pitched my mum and dad the gordon
ramsay scrambled eggs my mum and dad
went oh we've been doing that for years
that's not a gordon ramsay thing so this
is the mistake that people make with
scrambled eggs i didn't know people made
mistakes with it yeah you can make a
terrible grave arrow with scrambled eggs
you don't cook your scrambled eggs in a
frying pan way out no you don't do it
because this is what happens
they cook
at a very accelerated rate they get
powdery and dry and separated because
the pan is shallow and it gets very hot
right okay
and you're not supposed to do that this
is how you cook scrambled eggs and let
me tell you this is amazing the kill
when you serve the scrambled eggs
they're all
fluffy and light but also have a tiny
little bit of i call it on the turn you
know they're not quite fully okay like
solidified so you get a deep saucepan
not just a wanna sauce pan that's for a
bowl of soup but maybe a slightly bigger
saucepan that maybe you'd make
three or four bowls of soup in right
right or maybe five boiled eggs five
boiled eggs let's see carry on crack
three scrambled eggs if you're hungry
you can put four in there or even five
if you're a big strong man but let's say
three scrambled eggs right on a low heat
low heat william are you
are you breaking them right into the
sauce
right you're not whisking them in a bowl
no no no honestly trust me this this is
uh another thing that gordon ramsay said
if you if you whisk them in a bowl i
always do that no you shouldn't you're
already breaking up all of the flavors
in the scrambled eggs and you want to do
that slowly over time okay so crack the
eggs on the side of the pan on the
saucepan
into the thing into the thing that's
through them into the thing yeah and you
stir on a low heat with a wooden spoon
constantly stirring you want to get that
thing
kind of a little fluffy and full of
bubbles and aerating aeration
oxygenated oxygenated that's what they'd
say in the restaurant world right right
as soon as it starts to maybe change as
soon as it starts to maybe change the
consistency yeah completely raw it's
just starting to stick to the pan and
stick together a little bit you take and
i'm using this word correctly yeah a
knob
of butter
get your mind out of the gutter
uh i would say
three quarters of a tablespoon or a
tablespoon if you're feeling cheap oh a
large knob a big knob
now that
cools down the eggs of course it does so
now you're asking the eggs to slightly
cook then cool down slightly cook then
cool down you're keeping these flavors
in the eggs right stir in the butter
again once the eggs heat up take half of
the pan off the heat oh so it's cooling
down again heating up cooling up you
want to do that over the course of about
six or seven minutes so maybe
wait a few minutes to put the toast in
and as the toast is getting ready to be
finished that's when you're finishing
off your scrambled eggs right now what
gordon ramsay does i don't do this but
i'm sure it's a great thing
as the scrambled eggs is done you can
put a little dollop of
creme fraiche in there
no no no not for you really
watching your hips or or a little uh a
little bit of heavy cream oh heavy crypt
now don't now will you're going to
disagree with me here as well but this
comes straight from the top of most of
the proper most gordon ramsay and austin
in morning you don't season your
scrambled eggs until the last minute
okay so as it's all finishing and it's
got the consistency of maybe uh
a porridge you know half liquid half
solid you've got maybe 30 seconds left
of the next year
black pepper salt stir it all in and
then get it straight on your toast and
eat it and eat it ramsay said something
about the salt that the salt
will do something to it's either the
flavor or the consistency of the eggs
and you don't want to do it until the
last minute maybe it binds together
quicker if you salt it or something
i've cooked eggs scrambled eggs for
years in a frying pan and it's fine
after three minutes they're done and
they're all separated and not gray
uh
maybe because i'm coming to your house
at the weekend maybe
we'll do a little scrambled eggs treat
at the weekend
i'll tell you what i'll do then if you
do that
i will bake a loaf
so we can have fresh toast you're
scrambled eggs do you know what i'm
putting on the side of mine i don't care
what you're doing go on
jordan era oh
william what a treat the jardin era that
might be one of the best things we've
ever eaten on billion don't meet the
world and if you're feeling saucy you
put some marmite on your toast but
that's that's up to yourself that that's
all right we're done with the scrambled
eggs we've got more stuff that was
fantastic don i'm going to i'm going to
try that nick i'll let you do it at the
weekend but then i'll try it after that
but if i could and i don't want to be
demonstrative about this if i could have
you in the kitchen watching yeah just so
that i don't give it to you and go there
you go that was the method have you in
there going oh okay i'll see what you do
then oh i see i see i'd like that and
you don't mind me when you were doing me
when you whip
[Music]
we've had some fantastic suggestions for
where to put the singular swear word in
the lord of the rings trilogy if you've
got some knockout ones there that's one
of the best things that you've brought
up i love it i love it it makes me argue
i go into our youtube and our um and our
instagrams for the friendship onion and
then there's some some brilliant ones i
think it makes me laugh in the house
but i think we need to separate it into
funny ridiculous swear word that just
makes us laugh and a swear word that
actually makes sense yeah like the eowyn
to the witch king i am no
no i'm not [ __ ] men that would have
changed the whole time
oh
possibly even aragorn running into the
final battle for [ __ ] frodo i mean
that kind of that could work as a
serious i don't know i think i think
some of the army some of the army the
dead would have said oh well that's
quite funny that all right well what
have you got because i've got something
right here's one that hate me this one
is from
casa la maca oh hello what about that
casa malacca and he says when aragon is
throwing
kimly and helms deep
and he says
don't tell the [ __ ]
not brilliant
love that all right what have i got
i mean a classic one here from
sarah louisa lafaye
um gandalf falling into the uh balrog's
pit
fly you fools
[Music]
you've heard the theory that um gandalf
was actually telling us to get the
eagles at that point
he was about to tell us and then he had
to fight the balrog and then he says oh
fly your fools it's an interesting thing
i've heard that before right hold on and
we need to put the eagle thing to bed at
some point but maybe that's a later
never take an eagle a bed no never the
talons will
rip your eyes out but everyone has said
to us over the years why didn't frodo
even just frodo just get picked up by an
eagle he's flown over yeah doom thing
and dropped it it's not how it works no
it's not as easy as no it's not for one
thing there's no drama then well you can
say that any sure it's a sentence but
also we needed the fellowship as it were
to create so many distractions so that
sauron didn't know which halfling he was
looking for and if his eye was looking
right at an eagle flying across see
they'll get rid of that creature
hold on dom i've got one here but i've
written it in such a way that i can't
read it not the actual quote just the
name that's assuming um it's twilight
half
maybe elf
maybe huff
twilight something it's a shame you
can't read your own writing isn't that
it should have been adopted i know i
should have been very good i think
what's wrong with you
i just feel nervous you know just a
general sense of nervousness well just
take a couple of these scramble some
eggs you'll be all right you know i went
to school with a guy called richard who
became a doctor and his last name is
body doctor body isn't that great that's
good yeah deck body
yeah hey so twilight half health half
elf
said um
said and this is a good one and i forget
who'd uh
who's the name of the elf that dies and
helms deep is it how do you how dear
brilliance this is a how dear one could
have looked pretty powerful
brilliant yeah good snowboard i remember
he's a great actor yeah he's fantastic
and i really liked how i like him too he
says the dwarf breeze so loud we could
have shot him in the [ __ ] dark
brilliant
that's great here's one from from susan
underscore french x
and i think this sits in the category of
you could actually use this and it would
work in the film go
i win yep to the nas girl
if you want him come and claim him
that works i couldn't see her but she's
such a sweetie oh she hadn't lived very
rarely swears didn't she
uh get any more yeah i've got a few neil
mckenzie five uh sam to
uh gollum
potatoes
that's quite good had one the other day
i heard on the other day that was great
which is you and i after we've um
after we drank the ent draft
where i say i'm the
one
there's a lot there's a lot of people
we'll come back to it then yeah give us
one more well there's a lot of people
that have said you shall not
pass oh yeah there's probably 15 or 20
here yeah but i'll do one last one here
there's a lot of people that have said
when viggo breaks his toe he should just
go
which would have been it
he probably did
um
potatoes
is it gandalf who
oh it is
when when
legolas and gandalf the white now and
aragon and gimli meet us at
eyes and guards yeah i think under his
breath gandalf goes
[Laughter]
all right we'll do more next week please
send them in it's so much fun reading
them out hey hey what next i think we've
got some voicemails i think
hey guys this is remy here from france
congrats on the show is great now check
this out and what would a ranger know of
this matter
this is no mere ranger you stupid cup
[Applause]
nice one remy
that was that was pretty full on taters
yeah um that's a great one
yes that's great if you can do a
performance in the voicemail with your
swear words oh i would say manifest
we would love that um now a few weeks
ago
on billion dollar meet the world we had
a chilly crunch pace called momofuku
and we have found the person that sent
it to us it's katie graves
from katzenville in md
md
she's a doctor
yeah
uh m d mana soda no menace
john
oh he's not got mate yes he has
maryland merrill memorial and we we've
this is very popular in maryland they
make cookies don't they we in in britain
we say maryland don't they but they do
it kind of merlin merlin merlin
um
and katie says i'm the one who sent you
the momofuku chili crunch and i'm so
glad you enjoyed it please be well uh ps
my family adopted a pair of mischievous
young cats from a shelter this weekend
so of course we named them mary and
pippin ah that's a beautiful thing
fantastic i love it
oh i do love that sound billy oh yes the
sound of another sale on shopify the
all-in-one commerce platform to start
running grow your business i love how
shopify has the tools and resources that
make it easy for any business to succeed
from down the street to around the globe
for all of you that don't know our very
own the friendship onion website is
powered by
shopify it is we absolutely love shopify
without it our lovely fans would have no
way of receiving our friendship onion
merchandise my girls shopify powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale it is an absolutely
brilliant setup that they have done it's
absolutely true shopify gains insight as
you grow with detailed reporting of
conversion rates profit margins and
beyond it's really more than a store
shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com all lowercase for a free 14
day trial and get your full access to
shopify's entire suite of features grow
your business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
onion right now
shopify.com
tom when i work out and even when i
don't work out i like to be comfortable
and that's why i was very excited when i
found fiore they offer premium
performance apparel all inspired by the
active coastal coastline of california
yeah i love them too billy everything is
designed to work out in but doesn't look
or feel like it they're so comfortable i
want to wear them all the time seriously
it's more comfortable than whatever you
are wearing right now that's true the
clothing really is brilliant you can use
it for any sport running uh i've got the
surf shorts which are fantastic any
sport that you can think of and they're
so good that you can wear them any time
you want yeah the ori is also 100
offsetting their carbon footprint by
utilizing better sustainable materials
for their products empowering your best
active life feel good about the things
you buy and also how they're made the
men's sunday performance jogger is a
perfect lounge and work jogger i'd wear
them every day if i could and sometimes
i do fiori is an investment in your
happiness for our listeners they are
offering 20 off your first purchase get
yourself some of the most comfortable
and versatile clothing on the planet at
viuri.com
onion that's
v-u-o-r-i dot com slash onion and not
only will you receive 20 off your first
purchase but enjoy free shipping on any
us orders over 75 dollars and free
returns go to viori.com onion and
discover the versatility of the ore
clothing
we've also had a ton of suggestions from
people asking us to get in touch with
the actual person who makes momofuku and
have them on as a guest so if anyone
knows the person who makes momofuku
chili crunch we'd love to have them on
as a guest please let us know now
emergency bracelet emergency bracelet
which um my son is now still wearing as
a belt
he uh
we still don't know who sent it
so we need some help out there if you
know or if you're the person who sent us
the emergency bracelets and emergency
key rings could you let us know by
sending an email to the friendship onion
at cassmedia.com or send a voicemail at
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion yes and while you're at
it if you can rate review and
specifically subscribe to our podcast it
puts us in a place of being able to make
more and more podcasts yeah just do it
the whole subscription thing is really
key you guys because then you'd have to
go look for it it just shows up in your
phone and uh
we can make more and more episodes and
who wha
for the people that watch it on youtube
uh this uh how important is the likes
i'm actually asking you dom yeah likes
are very important i would think it's
the same as the podcast thing where it
allows people to see our podcast more
and more the amount of likes that we get
well could you could you like it out
there because people are uh i noticed
one of the comments said how
however many thousands have watched it
there was only like 800 likes
and somebody says why is this got so few
likes just like it just press the like
thumbs up thank you yeah as you're
watching it just put shadow your little
mouse over the thumbs up and just click
it it takes i mean a fraction of a
second i did i liked it i watched a bit
that you did and i thought i liked that
and i liked it
i've forgotten
i was i did actually have a song that
maybe we can use for housekeeping
to the uh melody of uh moon river we've
been doing a whole bunch of housekeeping
but maybe we use it next week which goes
like this
how's keeping
how much fun is this
keeping a house that's really clean
oh no it wasn't this no that was good
wait housekeeping huh
how much fun are you yes keeping a house
that's really clean and true
and true
else be true well that's true in the old
fashioned sense of like has honor
yeah i like it
so maybe we'll someone could slap a
little bit of a drum and bass thing on
there or some sort of beat and we can
use it as our regular housekeeping
jingle because you do all the jingles
yeah we'll do it yeah it'd be nice to do
an awful one like mine i love that one
whiskey
what about it lots of correspondence
about last week's episode about whiskey
i liked it i'll read one out now this
this is from
kiana weatherby what a great name
weatherby
on youtube
who said whiskey for usefulness i think
your scores were kind of low oh yeah
whoa
it's great for toothaches yeah hot
toddies for a cold great for numbing
pain think old west in american civil
war towns and if you need to sleep due
to insomnia it's great too yeah lmao
laughing
i would give it eight out of ten for
medicinal purposes yeah we did forget
that whiskey was almost used as a mild
medicine back in the day yeah fairy tale
on youtube agrees and said whiskey is
very useful two tablespoons and a cup of
english breakfast tea makes a cold go
away drinking it straight gets rid of
sore throats helps with indigestion
spelt indigestion wrong but that's okay
that doesn't matter but what you're
absolutely right when i was a kid and
you had toothache your mum would put a
cotton ball and whiskey and stick it
where the tooth was were
slobbered there on my own finger
so a tiny little kid's drinking a tiny
amount of alcohol which has some numbing
painkilling and that's and also it
probably got you a little drunk so you
didn't care about it so much that's what
scotland's like yeah jen l from oh how
do you say that
[Music]
new it's in um york state yeah i knew i
said hello there just put i just
discovered your podcast so i'm still
catching up well subscribe uh jen yeah
and perhaps this has already been asked
and i haven't heard yet however i heard
you both discussed music many times
already on your show and i was wondering
what type of music you think mary and
pippin
would be into if they were in our
current world do you think mary has a
secret fondness for barry manilow don't
we all or maybe pippin rocks out to ac
dc
back in black oh mandy
you came and you'll laugh without
i think she's i think she gave without
taking it doesn't she i don't think she
left oh no i think she gave him but
didn't ask for anything
and then he sent her away
[Music]
kiss me and stop me from shaking he must
have been freezing so a wet night he
must have been outside in the rain to
his bones yeah i think mary would love
barry manilow i could see mary listening
to barry by the way i mean the the the
actors on
the lord rings films were listening to a
plethora of different music but the
hobbits
zeppelin i think they'd definitely be
listening to let's say yeah
well zeppelin love the hobbits they love
middle east don't they yeah um and i
don't know if people know this but
pippin in the party scene is playing the
uh mandolin in the band
that's right when uh on stage when sam
sees um rosie cotton and stuff
uh
it was a nice little thing with the
writers it was philip a boy and so said
you actually play don't you i said yeah
and they said why don't you go up and
join the band then oh great
orange
no no i'm a mandarin amanda lynn
mandolin and there's little spanish
cakes where's the thing where you can
cut your fingers off accidentally uh
hunting knife no if you're playing
you're cutting a nail point in very thin
slices oh julianne julianne yeah if
you're cutting it julienne the thing
that you cut it on i think that's called
the mandolin as well is it i think so
brilliant well we've got a guest
should we reposition our posteriors and
bring in our guests i think we should
it's a very exciting one how do you i
know i get and there's another thing
that i get the heebie-jeebies about
i'm currently warming our seat for our
guests
if i sit on a seat that has been
accidentally warmed for me yeah does
that is that annoying does it go well
you're going to sit in this one right
you've warmed mine i hate that
so we'll bring on our guests but billy
why don't you just give the audience a
little back story on our wonderful
mystery guest
sam regal is a los angeles-based voice
actor and emmy award-winning voice
director known for his roles in
animation and video games as well as
co-founding the massively popular hit
show and media brand critical role and
executive producer of the legend of vox
machina critical role has become one of
the most popular storytelling and world
building independent media companies in
the world and sam plays a vital role
within the company as a co-founder
primary cast member for the flagship
show and executive producer of the
legend of vox machina animated series
which airs exclusively on amazon prime
video fantastic you did say flag sip but
i think you meant flagship but that
doesn't matter cause let's bring in sam
come on sam
we're back
wow william and we've been joined
two
ah right
bye
sam regal hello sam how's it going it's
going great how are you two we're great
we're very happy to have you here for a
bunch of different reasons because first
and foremost
billy has always been a little confused
about dungeons and dragons having your
bills i have and i'm i'm still slightly
confused but if i'm honest and i would
say that you're a dungeon dragons expert
right i i am a professional yeah player
at this point so yes
what was i brought here to this show to
just be like a tutor is that is that
what this is this is mainly why you're
here you're here to try and have
billy
understand
leave the show with it with a general
understanding of what dungeon dungeons
and dragons is we obviously want to talk
about critical role which is
an amazing story from just you guys
playing dungeons and dragons to it
turning into an amazon prime show and
everything in between but should we
start with
a little
idiot's guide hello to
dungeons and dragons because yeah i
think that's probably a good idea we
will get on to vox machina and all that
of course which i've been watching it's
fantastic thank you i thank you
why it's fantastic uh in a little bit
but to start off well i know three is
probably not the best number for a
dungeon dragon's game fine it's okay to
play with two people you can play with
you i play with my two kids uh and
that's that's a that's a three a three
person game we have a a great old time
so one dungeon master and two players so
let's assume at this point like let's
pretend there's a table in front of us
with the dye and a map and you're the
dungeon master and you're explaining to
an idiot so so billy i mean first let's
just get some bass line here have you
done any acting before i've done a
little before okay okay that's good your
bankroll was absolutely incredible and
and to be honest in london they still
talk about them they do
wow yeah i'll remember that this isn't
whiskey by the way sam though oh what is
that this is
a scarlet it's an energy drink scarlet
male cow
disease oh well we're not allowed to say
brand names well otherwise they don't
have to give us cash to do that yeah we
will see it for cash
um well as an actor you know you you
sink your teeth into a character and you
play that character for the whole
project whatever you're on it's the same
way with dungeons and dragons or other
role-playing games you you pick a
character for yourself okay you control
that character
and just like in the real world or in a
movie or a tv show uh other characters
are doing other things but you get to
sort of you you are the you are the hero
of your own story so you get to control
your own uh hero character your dungeon
master or game master will lay out uh
like a
uh a situation for you let's say uh
he'll say uh or she'll say um you walk
into a tavern and over in the corner
there's uh an armed
uh soldier uh carrying a spear uh in the
other corner there's a bartender who's a
dwarvish man gruff man and and then near
near the door looking a little uh cagey
is a as a cat person uh with a shield
and then you get to say what you and and
then the gm will say what would you like
to do you can go or order a drink you
can talk to any of those people you can
you can pull out your sword and and
challenge someone to a fight anything
you want to do
i'll go to the cat person
and say are you
would you be open to selling that shield
ah well then she might say to you uh
who's asking what's your name my name is
tarnis
of the house
bottom felt
bottom felt i
soft
i think
i think i've got bottom felt i've read
uh i've read pamphlets from the bottom
felt house and they're very racy well
yes
well i some of them have center folds
you know my sister
that's your sister
susan bottom felt
well tarnish thomas bottom felt and i
need a shield
for my next adventure oh what is your
next adventure i don't i don't at this
point well then it's fortuitous that
we've met for i have an adventure to
send you one oh good
see and then it just goes from there
guys we could keep going for hours but
we're not gonna because this is a
podcast
because that's just starting to make
sense there you go and then also sam
what so that's kind of general
introduction tends to always happen and
then sometimes billy's character might
find himself in a crucial
decision-making system oh yes where this
is where the dice comes with the dice
yeah
i think yeah that's just better so
in these types of games you can do
anything you can talk to people you can
go try to rob the tavern and steal all
of its gold but the harder the thing is
that you're trying to do
uh it requires a roll of the dice so
picking up a
a uh an ale and drinking it won't that
takes no effort at all however if you're
trying to steal someone else's ale
without them knowing you'll have to roll
a dice a dice roll to see if you are uh
lucky enough or fortuitous enough to do
it and you get bonuses for certain
character categories that you're better
in if you're if you're a nimble assassin
or something you might have a bonus uh
to stealing or something like that or if
you're uh if you're an entertainer you
might have a bonus when you're trying to
convince someone or lie to someone or or
confuse someone so uh but you can do
anything you can try to jump from one
building to another it's just if you
roll a one you're gonna fail and your
your game master will describe oh you
slip off of the bricks and you lose your
footing and you fall 20 feet to uh to
injure yourself
tom it's the new year well it's quite
far into the new year now but if you're
sticking to your new year promises to
yourself i'll tell you what can help
magic spoon whether you want to be
healthy or you want to get your mornings
going quicker magic spoon will help give
us some facts tom i'll give you some
facts right now zero grams of sugar 13
to 14 grams of protein and only four net
grams of carbs in each serving and it's
only 140 calories per serving build your
own box available flavors to build your
very own custom bundle are cocoa fruity
frosted my favorite peanut butter mmm
blueberry cinnamon cookies and cream and
of course maple waffle they are
absolutely delicious dog i tell you that
and you can go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and start your new year off
right be sure to use the code
onion at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
unlike other restrictive diets and
workout programs noon weight uses
psychology to empower you with the
practical knowledge and skills you need
to build smarter more sustainable
long-term habits and behaviors
noom isn't like other trendy diets it
actually helps you to get to a healthier
you which is why i love using it noom
allows it to be about the process with
ups and downs i hate a diet when it
feels like you can't eat anything but
noom actually educates you on how to be
healthy to reach your goals you're the
boss you decide how noom fits into your
life not the other way around 5 10 or 15
minutes a day how much time you want to
spend on the app it's up to you more
than 60 percent of users lose 5 or more
body weight by 16 weeks and more than 60
of users engaged with the program keep
the weight off for a year or more noom
is driven by a singular mission to help
as many people as possible live
healthier lives through behavior change
they use the latest improving behavioral
science to empower people to take
control of their health for good and
through a combination of psychology
technology and human coaching their
platform has helped millions of users
meet their personal health and wellness
goals sign up for your trial and get
psychology-based support and motivation
to reach your goals at n o o m dot com
slash onion that's n o o m dot com slash
onion to sign up for your free trial
so so
wait a minute so if i'm a warrior yes
and actually i'm gonna i'm gonna fight
the cat person i want to battle them yes
and dom's not a warrior he's a musician
sure that's yeah uh so
and we're both gonna do it
is it easier for how do how why is it
easier for me to roll this way it's
easier for you to do some things some
things that require strength like
punching hitting and swiping with swords
built into your camera however would you
then
dom over here if he's a musician or a
bard uh a character that i've that i've
played before
um uh he may have musical magic uh or
that can be activated by his his voice
or his his loot or his liar and so he
might not rely on brute strength to
conquer the foe he might rely on uh his
cunning and also his his musical magic
but then would the dungeon master say
if you roll a five or six you win
or how how does the rolling work it gets
a little bit more complicated where when
you get into combat because people have
yeah hp and it becomes a little bit more
like a video game or a traditional board
game where there's multiple roles and
you're losing
hit points and stuff and if you can get
them them down to zero hit points you've
won the battle
um or if they sort of submit you can
also intimidate them to stop fighting
and that sort of stuff in the last this
last dungeons and dragons game that i
played i played a halfling monk some of
you would have been one i was marvelous
so basically like a hobbit monk and some
of the things that he came with was that
he was dexterous i had a very powerful
kick that could act like a halfling that
could either push people away right or
obviously like a little bit of a karate
kick but if you needed to gain distance
from someone that's close to you the
attacks like crazy yeah you can kick
them run like crazy another thing that i
had built in it was either built into
the monk
character or maybe the halfling counter
was
if i tried to do something excuse me
sneaky like pickpocketing or lock
picking and i failed the first time i
had a chance that's happened
yes so you have these things
right so
on your character and your class and
stuff you get different advantages and
disadvantages and you try to play the
character uh to to the to those
strengths
or against those weaknesses and it's
it's real fun for me it's fun to just
sort of sink my teeth into
a character any kind of character but
also i love
i love failing it's just so great in a
story to fail because it leads to
awesome clever moments uh of inspiration
and ingenuity and
um it's just real funny to me
carry on no because i was slightly gonna
change the subject but i think you
should carry it i was going to slightly
change the sub not really i'm staying on
the subject but i'm interested in the
character building thing
because when i was watching vox machina
am i pronouncing that correctly yes
vox machina you're doing it
perfectly
when i was watching vox machina and
knowing the background of you guys
playing dungeons and dragons
and am i right with these characters
that are now in vox machina yes we
started as just a group of friends who
were playing at each other's homes
and we were rolling dice and playing as
these characters and and over the years
we
sort of fell in love with the stories
and the characters and and developed
them and got further and deeper into
their backstory until finally we
we realized we could tell this epic
story in a lot of different formats as a
as a live play show on twitch or as an
animated series we also have comic books
with these characters and it's really
cool but they all came from this home
game and i think that's what what makes
it so brilliant to watch
is it's not like
it's just came from a writer and then
you put a voice you can tell these
characters have lived lives and and they
have history and and as you see when
there's when there's mistakes it's it's
kind of wonderful to watch how they get
out of it
i was watching it last night and just
thinking
this is
sort of in the way that
a
russian theater
russian theater i i saw some great
chekhov
and in russia and they play the same
characters
all the way through their career oh
really if you're doing the cherry
orchard you're playing
a character in the cherry orchard
why not
yeah and then when you're too old for
that character you switch to another
character and and because of that when
you're watching it there's a sort of
you you sort of sink into your seat and
delight in the sort of depth of the
character and i felt that in vox machina
lived in that you're like this isn't
just a voice this is like these
characters are it's a unique
yeah it's a unique thing because we the
individuals who play the characters came
up with the characters and and have
lived with them for years and years now
um so yes there is that depth of
storytelling and backstory and stuff but
there's also fart jokes you know yeah
there's fart jokes yeah there is it's
great and you're you're a dusty bugger
in it i know i'm sorry about that that's
great and it'll grow on you you guys
also have a fantastic
chemistry as a team so if one if one
player in the group might be weak at
problem solving there's a character that
is good at problem solving or if
someone's not that great in battle the
other one can stand at a distance and do
something magical that's one of the key
things about dungeons and dragons right
is to have yeah you want a well-rounded
group
of legends slightly legally
we'll do a league of legends update at
some point but let's can we go can we go
back sam so please because we want we
want to kind of talk about the origins
of
vox machina and for people out there
that maybe don't play
dungeons and dragons i guess we've
covered the kind of basics of it it's a
tabletop game storytelling game yeah
it's shared storytelling and you're
you're sitting around a table with your
friends and coming up with stuff it's
ongoing that you you can have maps you
can use the dungeons and dragons company
itself to to provide you with maps or
you can use your own maps yeah you can
draw draw little doodles on a piece of
paper or like when i play with my kids i
i go to their i raid their box of legos
and i build things with legos that they
can they can visualize nice yeah so you
guys started playing dungeons and
dragons just privately as a group you
you create these characters that you
really liked and then you thought this
is actually a worthwhile group of people
telling a story that we think is decent
let's see if we can put up on put it up
on twitch which is a kind of youtube for
the gaming community
essentially right yeah i mean if you
want to get back to the real origins of
the very first time we ever played i was
talking to you guys about this in the
kitchen just shortly ago but i used to
do a podcast with my best friend liam
o'brien who's on mine
just like you two uh friends who do a
podcast we did a podcast and on one of
the episodes of our podcast
he said hey
you we should play we should play d d
together and i said i don't know what
that is but sure let's try it and and
that's that turned into critical role um
we did it as an episode of our podcast
so i'm what i'm saying here is you two
could stumble onto something during this
podcast that becomes
huge and ongoing me multimedia property
as big as critical rules yes or bigger
i hope bigger billy billy billy's a
massive star trek fan loves space loves
stories being told in space i love
sci-fi too we had got turned on to
another podcast uh
to the fact that there is a
a dungeons and dragons type game that is
all based in space it's intergalactic
stuff yeah you were salivating when they
told you remember you were drooling i
could be the captain you could be the
captain
so um we might we might explore that too
so we should do it so you love it
there's also a program that i played on
called critical role which is a digital
game playing program that allows people
to see the role of the dice in the
computer do you know this thing there is
something like that i don't believe it's
called critical role it might be called
uh roll 20. oh it might be called roll
20. you're totally right
yeah um but there's there's all kinds of
apps to to help connect people if you
can't meet in person to play and there's
really cool apps that can keep track of
all your stats and do all the math for
you so you can just focus on having fun
and not worrying about like oh i gotta
add this bonus and take away this bonus
and
yeah so you could be at your home on the
west side of la i could be at my place
we could have a dungeon master and they
could say okay billy it's your time it's
your turn to attack the giant or
whatever and you click a button and it
rolls the dice for you adds all your
bonuses tells you tells the dungeon
master how your score was and then
dungeon master tells you how you did so
here's my next question on it and
this might be
it's like how much power does the
dungeon master have
like as as the rules sort of like if you
were doing um
you know making up a a little improvised
scene is the rules where
like the dungeon master like he he
couldn't say you're dead and then that's
sort of spoilers no no no everyone
everyone has to follow the the rules of
the game um
the the gm or dm of of games like these
is
it's a weird it's weird because they're
the chief storyteller right they're
they're the ones who are
laying out the world uh and the scenario
for you to interact with
um but they're also a referee
right so settling any disputes that come
up about these role the the roles of the
dice but they're also kind of part coach
and they're they're giving you little
hints and tricks and tips and like hey
you might want to try to do this because
you might not know about this power and
so they're they're on they're sort of on
your team even though they're playing uh
people who uh who are not on your team
see i like that because even that little
five minutes we did in the tavern mm-hmm
that's great
and i thought i can i can maybe see how
this works now whereas before that i
just thought well i don't want to be
starting a big story and then the
dungeon master any poor point can say
well you didn't win or you
then it seemed there's no winning or
losing you're just trying to
create a story together bigger and
bigger and the characters become more
interesting i like it and like like a
computer game or a video game as they
say in the states
very often you start at level one and
then you get to a point based on
experience or or from doing something in
the game where you can get to level 50.
now if you're at level one and you meet
a level 25 wolf you can be in real
trouble but if you're at level 50 and
you meet a 25 wolf it's kind of easy for
you to okay kill them you know i i was
when i played that last game
the dungeons dragons game as that
halfling monk
i you know not very strong in fights so
i got to a point where i was kind of
touch and go and then you get a chance
to roll the dice three times to kind of
save your own life right if you if you
get knocked out or or
you're not quite dead yet okay you still
have a chance of of maybe staving off
death so you roll things called death
saves to see if you if you can stave off
the because the iron grip of death
so because you don't want to have been
building a character for course people
two years and then yeah and then is it
going not counting yes and this has
happened on our show like we've had
we've had characters just straight out
die
and then that's it years of time and
effort just gone and that's what makes
it so exciting you can actually die and
you can also do it the other way around
whereby you know the the the iconic dye
in dungeons and dragons is a 20-sided
die well that we're using dye in two
different ways now yeah dice you know
yeah the plural of yeah so
so you can be in real dire straight oh
god
we're going to make this we gotta die or
die and die all the same
you can be in trouble
and it you know you can kind of be
backed up into a corner and think i'm in
trouble here and if you roll a perfect
20 yeah then the dungeon master is like
okay you were in real trouble
you
climbed up the side of the wall and did
like a double flip and you landed on
your feet and you'd never done that
before in your entire life and at the
same time you caught a sword in mid-air
and cut the guy's head off and because
the chance of you doing it is one in 20
and you hit a perfect 20. sometimes it
happens like that right it does it's
very cool yeah yeah yeah 20's
it's it's a great it's great it's great
it's great for anyone you don't have to
be an actor you don't have to be a
performer to do it it's just fun to sit
around and i mean it's something that's
as old as time right people sitting
around
camp campfires or whatever yeah just
telling a story with your with your buds
um and maybe sipping a mysterious uh
urine colored beverage
so we go we keep um jumping around in
the in the time scale and that's
brilliant but so to go back you guys
started to
post
excuse me your
dungeons and dragons sessions on twitch
and it started to create a snowballing
amount of followers right everything
around it oh my my
mate was a weird angle
i've i've sorted that thing nice
yes we just we thought that it was by
the way we thought it was a terrible
idea to broadcast our our game we didn't
think anyone would want to watch it who
wants to watch a bunch of people sit
around and and play a game by themselves
for three or four hours at a sitting
with no edits yeah and it's not like
we're in costume and we're swashbuckling
around we're just sitting at a table in
street clothes sometimes munching on
pizza while we're playing it's not very
visually exciting yeah uh at least it
wasn't at the beginning and so um a
friend of ours felicia day asked us to
uh if we wanted to broadcast our games
on her twitch channel and we said no
it's stupid don't no absolutely not and
she said pretty please and we were like
all right we'll give it a shot and lo
and behold
we didn't expect it but people really
got into the characters in the world uh
and
they they started watching it like one
would watch a soap opera just really
invested in
where these characters are gonna go and
their romances and their faults and
um and also i feel like it unlocked um
something in the community that watches
us uh
a lot of them wanted to play games with
each other too and so uh our our amazing
critical role community they're called
critters the the people who watch the
show
a lot of them have found each other and
started their own uh d and d games and d
groups across the country or
internationally we've met people who
have gotten married because they met
another fan of critical role and started
playing d and d together and fell in
love and got married and
uh it's just really cool to to be a part
of something where people are coming
together and experiencing this this fun
together and that's storytelling as you
said
your
your show in a lot of ways could kind of
uh showcase a template for how to play
dungeons and dragons so people were like
oh this looks a little bit intimidating
how are these guys doing it and you can
watch oh they're all sat around and
there's a map and there's some totally
totally yeah
one of my buddies on the show travis uh
he always says this sports metaphor
where like if you took the rule book to
football uh
you would look really boring right yeah
but if you watch people play it it's
like oh that's exciting i could do that
so it's the same thing people are
watching us play and realizing like oh
it's not it's not super nerdy it's not
super mathy it's just fun you're just
just shooting you know and how long
were you on this twitch channel before
people started watching was that a slow
burn it was a slow burn i mean even even
now we
from the beginning i think a few hundred
people maybe watched and then the next
time it was
almost a thousand and and on and on and
on until now
tens of thousands of people watch us
every week sometimes more than a hundred
thousand live um and
uh and then after we drop the episodes
on youtube hundreds of thousands more
watch every week and
none of this was planned we still at our
core
we just like playing with each other
because we're friends i mean it's
amazing now that that all these people
are tuning in and invested in our
characters in our world
and we we as performers obviously love
spreading uh spreading it far and wide
uh
but our intent was just to kind of have
fun
so
the twitch channel yes critical role yes
starts to gain some traction starts to
snowball a little bit and and you start
to post some feed some stuff over to
your youtube channel at what point did
you
and the gang sit down and say
why don't we try and turn this into an
animated oh yeah why don't we make it
into characters that people can actually
see instead of it being voice sure well
the way that we all met as friends
initially is we're voice actors right we
all do uh animation and video games and
commercials and stuff with our voice so
we were all were always used to
playing characters that
eventually got animated
so it just i think in the back of all of
our minds
um
the game that we play is it's it's
almost like a radio play like there's no
there's no visual component so we were
always using our imaginations to
imagine like what these characters would
look like how how these battle sequences
would look and for a lot of us when when
we sort of closed our eyes and imagined
it we would always imagine it animated
just because that's the world that we
work in yeah um
so when our
more and more people started watching
the show
we thought it would be a great idea to
pitch an animated series version of our
characters and world so we went around
to all the big ones the netflix's and
disney's and all that stuff and we
pitched our show and everyone said no
they hated it they thought it was a real
stupid idea
um which you know to be fair probably
was at the time and so we were super
bummed for a while and then we realized
we have this cool amazing asset that no
one else has which is our amazing uh
fans outlaw the critter community who
really wants to see uh you know not just
our our characters out there but they
want to see us succeed and they've been
so supportive through this whole thing
so we threw it back to uh the critters
and said hey we want to make an animated
pilot can we raise some money so we did
a kickstarter
um for people who don't know what
kickstarter is
kickstarter is like dungeons and direct
no it's not uh kickstarter is just a
crowdfunding site like gofundme or any
other indie indie go go i don't know
what they're called anyway we we uh
solicited um
fundraising for to make an animated
series no an animated pilot
and they crack they destroyed our
expectations we ended up raising
millions of dollars a preposterous
amount of money
way more than we could have ever wanted
or asked for what was your initial
target what was the target that you set
animation is expensive so to make a half
hour animated pilot we were shooting for
750 000 which is like a moderately
budgeted half hour of animation okay
uh not super high end not super low end
kind of in the middle yeah and they
they raised 11.4 million dollars for us
a bananas amount of money
and
how long how long did that took 45 days
four if i you guys must have been
freaking out yeah yeah on the first day
i can't even remember the numbers but it
was millions the first day and we were
we were calling each other texting each
other throwing up you know i i i went to
the bathroom feeling dizzy it was it was
bizarre at no point did you think
i'm just gonna sever my ties with my
pals and draw that money just take it
all and go to cancun head to rio or
cancun
i wonder how many people how many of you
guys sat around and thought wait 11
million dollars
so you you so the idea was to make a
pilot to then shop it around again yes
to show
because it's such a strange concept yeah
so we wanted to make something to show
people yeah
so then we had we had all this money we
had enough to make a whole season of the
show without asking anyone exactly and
then you can keep it looking the way
that you want yes yes by
it looks fantastic who did the animation
we partnered with uh uh animation studio
called titmouse it's right it's right
here in fact you can probably see it
from this this window
it's in hollywood it's beautiful
remember when i went in so i was lucky
enough to play a a minor character in
this thing i'm a minor you're a super
important oh that's very sweet i went in
and i said to billy when i because we
were doing the podcast at the time i i
came out and i said to billy i saw a few
of the artistic renderings of the world
and it just looks incredible that i mean
i love animation anyway but just the the
buildings the the architecture the
characters i said to billy it's such a
stylish
animated piece and it is brilliant the
whole look of the world is fantastic
yeah they really did a great i mean titt
mouse is amazing they they do uh comedy
shows like big mouth and they do like
hardcore adult type shows like
metallocalips and stuff so they have a
lot of different styles but they're
super cool they got it immediately the
guy who owns titmouse is a long time d d
player he's had a long he's had a game
with the same friends for 20 years now
that they they keep playing um over and
over
and uh they just got it right away and
they helped us make this show and then
uh we when we embarked on on making it
with this amazing contribution of our of
our critter community we realized
we needed them to also see the show
and so we needed someone to put the show
on there yeah put their show up right so
that the
yeah um and so we we went around to all
those same meetings again with the the
disney's and netflix's of the world who
had passed on the project and wouldn't
you know it uh they were all like yeah
we'll take it
oh you've made it right that's brilliant
because i mean very rarely do you walk
into those meetings usually you're
you're saying to them we have an idea
can you help us make it yeah you're
walking into those meetings saying
here it is yeah do you want it yes such
a great power oh my god it was amazing
that's fantastic yeah our friend mark
odesky who we should have on the podcast
at some point
who ran fine line features excuse me
which is the kind of
uh
splinter group of new line that was
associated with making the mother rings
trilogy
he's been playing dungeons and dragons
for i think 15 or 20 years and a couple
years ago when i met
mark for lunch he brought his maps and
the maps are all discolored now over the
short years of playing it and they
started out like this and he's had an
extension and an extension and an
extension
we should have him on to bring those
maps and obviously talk about lord of
the rings but that's the great thing
about d d is if if you're into it it can
just keep going it can be a lifelong
passion or just a one night fun fun
things with your friends um but yeah we
we totally lucked out with the whole
process we landed at uh at amazon prime
video and they were amazing they they
gave us an amazing gift also they gave
us 14 more episodes
um that they financed and so we got to
make we're making two seasons of the
show
and it got to be translated into all
these different languages and and shown
around the world and we're just we're
just thrilled that we're just thrilled i
mean it's like it's
it's the top show on amazon just now yes
i mean yeah that is great and it all
came from you playing a game
and people wanting to watch it and now
look at it
wow that was sam i mean as creatives
isn't that what we all want to do
something that comes from a real place
they're having fun they're all voice
actors creating characters these
characters become
so real and then you get to make a show
about it it's a brilliant story and very
inspirational because he's able to say
we love what we're doing
we want to uh have the freedom to
continue to make our own artistic
choices so we'll crowdfund it from the
fans and then we have all the control
and all the power and like you said the
show speaks for itself is full of
passionate people working really hard
for a common goal vox machina on amazon
prime amazon check it out it's brilliant
and look back at the um critical role
these guys doing their stuff on the
internet is brilliant guys get in touch
with us send us all of your emails
that's uh the friendship on your
netcastmedia.com that's cass with the k
also if you leave any comments on our uh
youtube channels and wherever you get
your podcast we'll read them we have a
spotify playlist that you can check out
you can leave voicemails
we will be growing this community as
well we're growing a community
wait where can they leave voicemails at
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion fantasy and we'll see
you guys next week don't forget to rate
review and subscribe
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy's the baby you're my
[Music]